pete heck seth co-host to fox and
friends weekend pete you've been saying
it for more than a year now bill maher
is even saying it
absolutely um good for him long overdue
but good for him
and it was a great report by mark
meredith he's a fantastic reporter but i
come away from that even more confused
which is the which is how we've been
this entire time none of the guidance
seems to be actually healing to these
science
a lot of it seems to be hewing to
politics and then when you see mayor
garcetti saying he holds his breath and
then you see gavin newsom he's at the
game with magic johnson no mask for him
then you see stacey abrams sitting with
a bunch of kids looking like hostages
and she the one who would be vulnerable
isn't wearing a mask you see it's all
the ruse it's always been about
compliance it's always been about saying
it's the science mandates as you pointed
out harris lockdowns before that
vaccine passports is what they would
like to do parents have woken up and
thankfully they've had enough but here's
the cynical part i live in new jersey
harris i'm so ashamed i actually mean
this completely i am ashamed to admit
that i have three kids that still wear a
mask in school i it hurts my soul it
hurts my soul to say that you know it is
about to change we've tried to get
exceptions for them we haven't been able
to it's a state mandate
but the reason phil murphy is getting
rid of that mandate harris is not
because he's suddenly following the
science the science tells them it's okay
we've known that for over a year as you
pointed out
he's doing it because and you hear more
you're gonna hear more and more of this
harris democrats are worried about the
midterms their majorities in the house
and the senate joe biden promised a
return to normal and you're going to see
governors and others attempt to create
that return to normal not because of
science but because of politics phil
murphy knows how unpopular it is he's
going to say here to you here the masses
here's your crumbs tape off the mask now
elect us again so the next time there's
a variant we can throw masks back on
your kids
it's cynical but it's true march 7th
will be that magical date and the state
of new jersey the question is will
anybody follow and and with with what
we're talking about the science that had
popped early on it was that when people
came out of their houses we realized
after all the lockdowns that they
actually had a rate of covet that could
not be ignored but they said they hadn't
been anywhere and then now with this
johns hopkins university study looking
at all of it together
two dozen
packages of analysis any they call it a
meta analysis that they did well now we
know
now we know what we thought we knew and
now we have the receipts so which states
fold in connecticut let's take a look
there a mother jennifer orr is going
after school masked mandates pete saying
they're harming her our nation's kids
but she gives a personal example watch
this
my daughter is a senior at foreign high
school she looks over and she sees her
math teacher and she says oh my god hi
miss so-and-so and the teacher says
oh my god
hi
i didn't even recognize you i've never
seen your face before
layla's been in that class for three and
a half months
this is dehumanizing it's demoralizing
and these teachers
should see a human face
i saw that on facebook i wanted to show
it to you it it
actually made me cry
it gives me chills it gives me chills to
hear that because we talk about our
youngest and yes our youngest are are
it's the silliest that we wrap our
youngest in a cloth mask that we know
doesn't work as well and we know they're
not vulnerable but what about the the
teenagers what about the 16 17 8 year
old 18 year olds to this mother's point
who are never gonna get their prom back
they're never gonna get their senior
year back they're never gonna get the
opportunity to experience the things we
all took for granted because they were
right there in front of us and it's been
it's been heartening though hairs to see
these some of these students out in
california and elsewhere and a lot of it
comes back to look at my governor look
at my mayor mayor look at those
hypocrites who won't do this themselves
why am i going to continue walking dude
into a school if dozens and hundreds of
students will come together and say we
will not comply that's more powerful
than students than excuse me parents at
school board meetings who are doing
their best but ultimately the customer
the end user customer is the student and
if they just say hey we're done uh
especially in states where they're
lifting the mandate in virginia in new
jersey in a month um i think they could
have a cascade effect across the country
and i hope that's interesting
that that's really interesting by the
way we haven't even talked about the the
teachers unions in their role because
because the politics are all i mean it's
just it's it's a stew of politics right
and and governor murphy in new jersey is
not running in the midterm elections
he's got to help other people get there
right he just got reelected he can't do
that if people in his state don't want
to vote for democrats based on his
mandates
it's it's a vicious circle i want to get
to this it's been two years since the
death of dr wee lynn lee yang
he is the scientist who warned the world
that kovid was spreading throughout
china he called it a sars mystery
disease and that it was spreading and he
tried to get the word out with the video
that he was making i mean i remember
that from the beginning pete we talked
about it and now with more than 900 000
americans dead
we're not any closer to answers
on exactly the origins of this because
if you say wuhan laboratory in my
twitter feed i get stickered i don't
know about you house minority leader
kevin mccarthy is now vowing to
investigate china for this if
republicans if and when he says regain
power in november
watch
think about what nancy pelosi has done
as speaker
she has protected china from any
investigations to the origin of covet
even though it's killed more than 900
000 americans but we'll take action
when we take the majority we will
investigate the origins of kovitt
because you take the actions of the
democrats i do not know what china has
on these people but it must be so
powerful because the actions at every
turn stop and harm us but protect
china pete
he's right
why does it seem at every turn that
nancy pelosi and her ilk are more afraid
of say trump supporters
than they are of the communist chinese i
mean look at what she said to our
athletes over in
uh these games which our athletes
shouldn't even be participating in don't
speak out don't speak out the chinese
are like real hardcore
and they might why are we there why are
you talking in that way and why are all
of your policies willing to be complicit
to them we knew from the beginning where
this originated from in china there were
questions about how it came about and
there was an open discussion about that
we saw scientists try to stifle that
discussion including at the very top
in anthony fauci no don't talk about
gain of function don't talk about a lab
it's all natural origins and if you
talked about it even to this day
but especially at the beginning it was
misinformation you were censored to talk
about a lab leak then more and more
evidence much of its common sense comes
out that indeed it was probably
something manufactured the chinese
government knew a lot more about it
earlier than they told us about it yet
the democrats don't want to do something
about it they don't want to hold them
accountable it's insane and so the
republicans had better double down on
that investigation should they get the
chance you know how i i get so unexcited
about a hearing on capitol hill because
it's a lot of political
gestures and and posturing but i'd
actually like to see the hearing with dr
fauci
and and the like
i would like to see that hearing based
on what was going on inside that lab and
and not not a battle between senators or
making it personal none of that
i mean on the record very scientific we
need to know and if he can help get us
there
we need to ensure that that happens this
can be interesting he's for him too if
there's a red wave it will be very
interesting where we go next pete heck
seth
let's get to this before i let you go
white house national security advisor
jake sullivan warns russia
is ready to invade ukraine possibly any
day and how do they know because they've
got like 70 to 80 of the assets now all
in place for a full invasion
president biden is suggesting that
vladimir putin cannot be reasoned with
watch
we are in the window
any day now russia could take military
action against ukraine or it could be a
couple of weeks from now or
russia could choose to take the
diplomatic path instead if there's any
particular thing that vladimir putin is
looking for
i think things he cannot get
the u.s military has determined that if
russia invades it could seize the
ukrainian capital within 72 hours and
leave up to 50 000 civilians killed or
wounded
a senior russian diplomat called that
assessment alarmist
you served you've been to just some of
the toughest places in the world
is it alarmist to you or or what do you
think
i mean clearly vladimir putin has
ambitions to re-establish uh some uh
orbit of the former soviet union there's
no doubt about that that's what he's but
i don't i don't have any confidence in
you know jake sullivan or joe biden the
architects of the afghanistan debacle
nor do i have any confidence in in
general milly who's the one who gives us
this estimate of 72 hours he gave us the
estimate of the afghan army standing up
for a year or two so it's either going
to be seven minutes or seven weeks it
won't be 72 hours because we know he
won't be right the reality is
probably the olympic games when those
are over will be a trigger for
international action because they see a
lame duck president and ultimately
europe not willing to defend itself it
will be on the ukrainians how long can
they hold out nobody quite knows but the
russian war machine especially revamped
under putin is a dangerous one and they
have ambitions and now they're allied
with china we've pushed them into that
corner no good options
yeah i mean we didn't we didn't tell
we didn't tell putin to do this this is
what he wants to do and and i find it
fascinating pete that we're being told
what words we can't use like don't say
imminent that's what we got from jinsaki
last week at the white house press
briefing lectern don't say imminent
now we can't say alarmist
or or or if we tell the truth it is
alarmist like what is that about they
said the same thing about afghan i mean
don't don't say retreat um don't say the
taliban are providing our security no we
didn't leave equipment behind it wasn't
a failure they could say what they want
we see what's going on here i think the
american people do too weakness it's the
actions that matter uh pete hexa thank
you for getting us started this hour
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else